[Aplausos]
yo tenía un sueño y claramente no era
andar en esta silla aunque tengo que
aceptar que es divertido
soy un poco peligroso con la silla así
que cuidado
pero
pero de chico esto tenía otros sueños
no era lo que yo me imaginaba estar en
esta situación
tenía el sueño
más grandioso que un chico puede tener
yo quería ser recolector de basura
creo que es genético porque mis hijos
cada vez que pasan los recolectores de
basuras salen a la ventana los miran
mirar hasta que se vuelven papilla se
fue
evidentemente hay algo ahí adentro que
hay que estudiarlo pero bueno
la cuestión es que yo soñaba con ser
recolector no sé si se pusieron a pensar
en lo que es el recolector es correr al
aire libre saltar saltar del camión en
movimiento una cosa de lo come volaba la
cabeza
en ese momento yo no sabía
que en unos años me iban a diagnosticar
de una enfermedad neurodegenerativa
que no tenía vuelta atrás
es más
llegando a los 12 años 13 años jugando
al fútbol poniéndole toda la pasión del
fútbol se me aflojan las piernas
y yo vuelvo a mi casa contento y voy le
digo a mi papá no sabe lo que me pasó
hoy
corrí tan fuerte pero tan fuerte que se
me aflojaron las piernas
obviamente yo estaba contento mi papá y
eso así se sentó y dijo que estamos
medios complicados
fue pasando el tiempo y ya no era que se
me aflojaron las piernas de vez en
cuando sino cada vez era un poco más
seguido
me llevé educación física
el curso que no sé si alguien reprueba
educación física
y bueno fuimos a hacer estudios hacer
estudio a ver qué es lo que es lo que le
pasa que está perdiendo que está
perdiendo fuerza
fuimos un centro super especializado en
buenos aires donde me hicieron de todo
tipo de prácticas la que me quedó muy
grabado fue una electromiografía
electromiografía en una palabra extensa
y un poco complicada pero es básicamente
una tortura médica si te clavan agujas
de este tamaño en los músculos y te
tiran electricidad a ver si ese músculo
funciona a ver qué pasa si yo entiendo
que era parte del proceso ahora ahora
que lo veo desde otro lado
pero bueno en ese momento fue algo algo
traumático
y me acuerdo cuando terminó el día
tuvimos la entrevista con él con el
neurólogo especificado especializado en
enfermedades neuromusculares
nos tiro muchos diagnósticos que podrían
ser no nos tiro un diagnóstico
y
pero si nos dijo algo el pronóstico no
es bueno
qué significa que el pronóstico no sea
bueno para un chico de 14 años
esto da vuelta en mi cabeza que que es
no tener un buen pronóstico es
es morir es andar en silla de ruedas
e
quedar postrado en una cama
no sé era todo y no era nada porque uno
no entiende esas cosas
creo que no entré en crisis en ese
momento porque los vi tranquilos mis
padres y eso fue algo que siempre me
llamó la atención mantuvieron la calma
fuimos al auto se estaba oscuro
mi papá arranca arranca el auto pero no
marcha
en ese momento
me
me hace la charla más impactante de mi
vida seguirla en el tiempo fue la que
perduró no sé si en ese momento fue fue
un gran impacto pero en el tiempo
fue haciendo mella en mi vida
y me dice alan
voy a escucharte todo estaba con
nosotros en este momento vos tenés
que tomar una decisión tienes dos
opciones
una opción va a ser no hacer nada
va a ser quedarte en la casa no estudiar
no no hacer la una vida normal si se
puede definir de alguna forma la
normalidad
o puedes tomar el otro camino
que seguir viviendo un día a la vez cada
día según lo que tu físico te dé las
oportunidades que dios te vaya dando
no respondí nada yo
sabía que me iba a pasar en un tiempo es
más solicita bueno espero por lo menos
terminar el secundario aunque sea con un
bastón entonces puedo puedo no sé tener
alguna desarrollarme un poco mejor
arranco el auto y nos fuimos fuimos a la
casa de un tío que vive en buenos aires
en ese momento comenzó a venir la
angustia ya pasó el shock
y comenzó a venir la angustia bueno
familia me tengo que ir a bañar si
necesitaba estar sólo necesitaba
procesar eso que me estaba pasando
me meto la ducha que era una bañera hoy
pienso entrar a una bañera solo es casi
una utopía es con mucha ayuda tengo
imaginarse eso es bastante morboso pero
así que no lo hagan
efe
pero fue un momento de mucha angustia si
emprendí el aguafuerte
y sobre él fue un momento fue el momento
donde yo me angustia por mi enfermedad
fue el momento donde donde yo no veía
más allá de de ese día
y de repente se viene un pensamiento no
me habían dicho el nombre de la
enfermedad chau
yo tengo que ser médico tengo que ser
médico para descubrir mi enfermedad es
más le voy a poner mi nombre a la
enfermedad le voy a poner enfermedad de
kalbermatter
en ese momento tampoco sabía que ya
estaba recontra descrita la enfermedad
es una enfermedad rara y se llama
atrofia muscular espinal
y yo siempre hago el ejemplo que es como
el alzheimer de los músculos o de las
neuronas motoras sí que es lo que pasa
se van muriendo las neuronas motoras
igual que en el alzheimer las las
neuronas vinculadas a la memoria en mi
caso son las neuronas motoras entonces
de a poquito voy quedando sin fuerza del
cuello para abajo
el pronóstico no es bueno
eso sí
en ese momento
comenzó
hacer efecto la charla de mi papá si en
ese momento comenzó
hacer una charla teórica en una acción
comenzó
comienza a andar
fue el primer paso ese momento fue lo
que hizo destrabar
el mirarme
y darme lástima por lo que me va a pasar
en el futuro
no me estaba pasando en eso me podía
meter a una bañera era buenísimo estaría
buenísimo volver a meterse en una bañera
a ver hacía un montón de cosas solamente
se me aflojaron las piernas de vez en
cuando
me había llevado educación física sí
pero bueno es un detalle que me lleve
otras materias en mi vida entonces
tampoco era era tan grave
decidí andar decidí continuar seguí en
el secundario en el secundario y en esa
edad comienza
a ver un problema que es que es muy
fuerte y que se llama la inclusión o la
exclusión
y ahí entendí que la inclusión parte de
uno mismo y la exclusión también parte
de uno mismo tiene mucho que ver los
amigos tienen mucho que ver los amigos
tienen mucho que ver la familia tiene
mucho que ver la familia no sé mi viejo
nos mandaba a lavar el auto y yo no me
podía agachar y bueno mi hermano lavaba
las ruedas solas a los vidrios o sea no
iba a safar de lavar algo así
y así con todo la adaptación en el día
10 es muy importante con mis amigos
haber llegó un momento que no servía ni
para ir a largo bueno me pusieron y
director técnico no ganamos nada no me
daban bolilla
fue un desastre fue poco tiempo después
me quedaba mirando y alentando y
haciendo las charlas motivacionales
hasta ahí llega a mí mi rol en el fútbol
y terminó el secundario y me acuerdo
algunos momentos de exclusión en el
secundario por ejemplo en el viaje
estudio fue a mendoza montaña montaña
para alguien con dificultad es
complicado qué es lo que hacían mis
compañeros me cargaban me llevaban los
momentos donde yo no fui fue por una
decisión propia no no quiero no quiero
que me al pse no quiero que me vean
arriba de otro no me incomoda fueron
momentos internos sí
y eso es una de las cosas que quiero que
queden
la inclusión o la exclusión comienza de
parte de uno comencé en la universidad
en ese momento todavía podía caminar
bastante bien
con más dificultad que antes pero pero
caminaba bien al pasar los años como
comencé medicina una carrera larga una
carrera que que lleva mucho tiempo
mis músculos se comenzaron a debilitar
porque mis neuronas ya no mandaban el
mismo impulso nervioso
y esos pasillos de los hospitales
cada vez se hacían más largos y las
escaleras eran más altas
revisar un paciente sí
me complicaba
pero había un objetivo y era terminar
medicina
y los objetivos cuando son reales
no se cambian no se cambian por las
circunstancias y mi objetivo no iba a
cambiar por las circunstancias
se iba a modelar por las circunstancias
porque cuando termine
medicina tuve que decidir qué
especializa qué especialidad hacer y yo
cuando comencé medicina pensaba hacer
otras cosas
y a ver qué puedo hacer hoy puedo
caminar dentro de un tiempo no sé listo
tengo que hacer algo que me sirva y que
esté sentado así que puede ser me gusta
la psiquiatría listo vamos a siguiente
ya nos metemos por psiquiatría sí
volviendo un poquito atrás
a la universidad también una de las
cosas que me preguntaba era si va a
poder tener una familia si va a poder
tener hijos que queda lo que iba que era
lo que iba a pasar en mi vida personal y
social
me preguntaba si si esa chica que me
gustaba desde los 13 años alguna vez me
daría bolilla si estaría interesada en
mí
en una persona que tenía y tiene un mal
pronóstico
aún así contra todo pronóstico
y gracias a la insistencia
[Risas]
me pude casar me pude casar pudimos
tener hijos
no somos una familia tradicional ahora
ella lava el auto y yo soy el que dobló
la ropa
no sé cambiar el pañal de un de un bebé
sin fuerza es un toque complicado porque
una patada
es diferente no me duele pero me puede
hacer caer o sea
tiene sus partes lindas y tiene su parte
adaptativas también
mis meses de tres años saben que
caminando sí porque yo puedo caminar
como endebles pero camino saben que
mientras que yo estoy caminando no me
tienen que tocar si no somos la típica
familia que vamos todos de la mano no yo
tengo que ir a agarrar mi esposa si
vamos caminando
nos fuimos adaptando
de nuevo las circunstancias no cambiaron
los objetivos los objetivos personales
los objetivos académicos quien se iba a
imaginar que en el tiempo esos pasillos
y esos caminos esos esos lugares los iba
a poder transitar sencilla y a poder
hacer docencia y a poder trabajar en un
centro en la universidad donde
se ayuda a alumnos que se les está
haciendo cada vez más alta las escaleras
y cada vez es más largo los pasillos
y que esas escaleras y esos pasillos
ponen en jaque los sueños de cada uno
y hoy esta mañana me pasaba cuando pasó
el basurero
bajaron los recolectores tiraron la
bolsa de basura adentro y mi hijo estaba
ahí y yo pensaba
cuáles serán sus escaleras cuáles serán
sus pasillos
qué pasará yo no los conozco a todos
ustedes no sé cuáles son sus escaleras
cuáles son sus pasillos cuál es su mal
pronóstico con qué mal pronóstico se
están enfrentando o se van a enfrentar
pero siempre es muy pero muy importante
que ustedes sepan que es lo que te hacen
dar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]